why has hydrogen not taken off in the
united states then i'm curious
it's just too expensive yeah but we've
driven that down now so now you see the
whole world's talking about hydrogen now
because of eco like
three years ago you couldn't even talk
about hydrogen now it's the talk of
everything around the world europe's you
know spending hundreds of billions on it
everyone is now
so so the rest of the world tried to
figure out hydrogen
power cars and trucks they couldn't
figure it out
and then you guys came along and you
figured it out exactly because cars are
a terrible idea a lot of times with
hydrogen
they pick the wrong market these guys
are i mean it's insane it's stupidity
they went after the like cars people
want a 30 000 car they don't want a
hundred thousand dollar
cheap car they want to you know when i
say cheap that means like it doesn't
give you that it's not like you're
buying a
a g wagon you're buying a tiny little
car and you're spending a hundred
thousand dollars
it'll never work the reason why hydrogen
works on big trucks is because you make
revenue with it you can pay it
back and you can it's all about weight
and it's all about
range and you get range and weight with
hydrogen you don't get that with
batteries
so in cars battery is awesome man this
is the thing we're honest with people
because we sell both battery and
hydrogen so we're very honest with
people about what the advantages are and
when you get into cars and light duty
battery is the best thing you get into
heavy duty hydrogen's the best thing
so they pick the wrong market to go
after it's stupid it makes sense and
so also i you guys are making when you
do the routes you're pre-selling the
route so you don't have to
incur the cost of building this route
let's say it was from
arizona to texas or something um just
making something up here
uh but you're based in arizona so
betting man i would say
the the if you do get this anhyzer bush
thing up and running would be
in that southwest category am i correct
or that it could be yeah we have there's
two or three routes they have in this in
this western area we're definitely going
to focus on those for sure right away
and so those repeated routes de-risk you
because you don't have to take on the
capex
structure without a customer so
previously
the people making the hydrogen hydrogen
cells
trucks and making the stations were all
different people nobody had the ability
to build it
and then people would come and then
people would uh actually
exactly well there's a difference of us
everyone else so think about a company
called clean energy they used to build
natural gas stations
they spent hundreds of millions all over
the country actually billions i think
and no one ever came to fill out them
and so they just like built these things
hoping people would come nikola is
totally different we only build the
order
that means we pre-sell a route we put a
station on it and we make hundreds of
you know
we make either tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of dollars on that
route over time
so we just keep building them every
every single route we do we can make
a quarter million dollars a truck and
that's the margins are huge compared to
our competition
and that's why there's so much
excitement about nikola because we've
done a couple things one
we made the second dirtiest industry in
the world go
zero emission we've we create 10 to 20
times more revenue
per truck than our competition our
margins are gigantic
and we have 10 billion over 10 billion
dollars in pre-order reservations like
like customers signed ready for us to
deliver them trucks